one of the things that i've learned in
my business is that the mistakes are
where all the learning is and actually
the mistakes and the imperfect stuff
that's where the gold is and so as
you're sitting there and you're thinking
about doing stuff and you're trying to
make it perfect and you're trying to
come up with the right script before you
make that cold caller you're trying to
make sure your body looks perfect before
you put yourself out there on match you
are missing out on your life i hope that
if there's one thing that i consistently
inspire you to do it's to start before
you're ready it's to put yourself out
there and make mistake it's to have
yourself go live and have it look like
and all of a sudden you disconnect
yourself and to be able to laugh at
yourself to be able to shake it off like
that is a skill it's a skill that means
that you're self-aware it's a skill that
means that you're growing
need motivation you better watch a top
10 with believe nation hey it's evan
carmichael and i make these videos
because you are probably the most
ambitious person in your circle but you
know you're capable of more and you get
that push by surrounding yourself with
the best so today let's learn from one
of the best mel robbins and my take on
her top 10 rules of success enjoy
rule number two don't run away there's a
lot of you
that are running from things
instead of running two things
and that's a huge difference running
from something versus running to
something and so i want you to think
about that for a minute um because you
don't have to move across country to
change your life
and you don't have to do something
drastic to experience drastic positive
change
and here's the thing about running away
from your problems
running away from your past have you
ever noticed that when you run away
it tends to follow you
you know i used to uh have this problem
in relationships
and the reason why i had this problem is
because i was a very unhappy person
i didn't like myself truly as a person
until probably four or five years ago i
spent as sad as this is i spent the
first 46 years of my life really not
liking myself really um feeling like i
wasn't a good person
really questioning the sanity of people
that were in love with me or that were
friends of mine because i had such a low
opinion of myself and it didn't matter
you know i i was guilty not of moving
from one city to another
but i was guilty of moving from one
person to another
that i would literally
get in a relationship i would be in a
relationship for a year and then i would
start to feel that unsettled feeling
because what happens after a year of
being in a relationship well you got to
start working on it it's no longer the
thrill and the delight and it's new and
you're dating
now it's just you and the person in your
life
there's nothing new about it and so all
your old crap starts to show up and
that's when you got to start to do the
work and so it was about the year or the
year and a half mark in almost every
single relationship that i would start
getting that itchy feeling and the
reason why i was getting that itchy
feeling is because my past was now there
this new relationship was no longer new
and so i was no longer distracted by it
and i was going to have to
deal with myself in order to be happy
and so what did i do for years not even
just years decades everybody i'm not i'm
not proud to admit this but i would
literally jump out of one relationship
and into another new one because another
new one would distract me from the fact
that i was an unhappy person
true story
and i think a lot of you who are unhappy
with yourselves are looking to move jobs
or looking to move uh the city that you
live in or you're looking to change your
relationship and the problem isn't where
you live the problem isn't your job the
problem isn't the person that you're
with the problem is how you feel about
yourself rule number three validate
separate and celebrate if you're not
facing a breakup personally in your
romantic life you still want to pay
attention because somebody that you care
about might be and this is advice that
you can give to them also breakups uh
happen in your career
you might be breaking up with a work
situation you might be breaking up with
a friend i know a lot of us are working
hard to draw boundaries and to surround
ourselves with more positive people and
we get questions every day about how you
do that and so breaking up with friends
can be just as traumatic as breaking up
with somebody that is a romantic partner
i have three steps to getting over a
breakup that i'm going to explain in a
minute but first i want to under i want
to explain some research to you to help
you put what you're feeling into context
because what you're going through when
you break up with somebody or you're
broken up with
is you literally
go through withdrawal
i'm not kidding and yeah i'm using the
word withdrawal where else do you hear
the word withdrawal you hear the word
withdrawal when you hear about people
withdrawing from a drug
and that's a lot uh similar to what
you're going through in fact there was a
study done by neuroscientist lucy brown
who found that like drug abuse romantic
love begins with that euphoric feeling
it's a high right
and when the drug leaves your body or
the romance leaves your life what are
you left with you're left with the
withdrawal which is a craving for it
validate number one
breakfast breakups are painful but they
don't need to lead you broken
so i want you to validate where you're
at it's great that you're asking the
question you got to have a little bit of
compassion for yourself you got to
understand that you're going to be sad
for a while but please don't pour
gasoline on the sadness fire please
please please don't be staring at photos
of your ex please don't be
putting his or her social media face
right in front of your face it's going
to make it worse but definitely validate
the sadness because you're going through
a major change and it might not be a
change that you wanted number two
separate this is the most important part
because the other thing that i don't
think any of us realize is that when you
get broken up with or you break up with
somebody
you don't realize how much of your daily
routine and the habits that you have and
the way that you go about your day was
tied to the person that you're no longer
with and so what you're not only dealing
with is not only missing the person but
your whole
life schedule
may have just been thrown off maybe you
two went to the same gym in the morning
maybe you got a text in the morning from
this person maybe you liked your little
facetime call at work maybe
your friend group became their friend
group and now all of a sudden that
you're broken up because you hung out
with their friends all the time you
don't have that social life anymore and
so it is so important for you to
recognize that you're not only facing
the person being gone but the habits
that marked your day and the other
people that maybe you hung out with and
the things that you did with your time
and the music that you listened to and
the food that you ate that those might
have all been dictated by the person you
were with and those are changing too so
it's important for you to separate your
self i think a lot of women in
particular when we get into a
relationship we tend to lose ourselves
we tend to morph into the person that
we're dating i used to do that all the
time
and so
now we get to the third part
as you start to think about separating
right so you're validating where you're
at you're separating from this person we
need to get to the third part which is
celebrating you
now that you're broken up you have an
opportunity you have an opportunity to
rediscover yourself because i guarantee
you you lost a bit of yourself in that
relationship and so as you think about
the way that the structure of your day
is changed what can you proactively
insert that is a celebration of the
things that you stopped doing
what have you been keeping yourself from
doing because you are in this
relationship that would celebrate you
who are the friends or family members or
colleagues that really lift you up and
how can you find more time to hang out
with them this is a time to celebrate a
moment when you get to rediscover you
rule number four learn to speak up i've
looked into the research there's only
one
habit and skill just one
that has a direct impact on how much
money you make a direct impact on
whether or not you get the promotion and
the influence and the cash
money that you deserve and you know what
that is
any ideas
the one skill
the one habit
the one thing that has a meaningful
behavior change that impacts
what you get
it's your visibility you see you don't
get credit you don't get paid for and
you don't get graded on the things that
people can't see
in order for you to get what you deserve
you have to start being deliberate about
your visibility behavior that you've got
to start learning to do whether you're
shy
whether you're introverted whether
english is your second language it
doesn't matter you've got to learn how
to speak up you've got to learn how to
share your ideas you've got to learn how
to talk about your business you've got
to learn to talk about your dreams and
your goals and i know for many of you
that is one of the most terrifying
things in the world you hate being the
center of attention the idea of speaking
in a meeting at work and risking
sounding like you don't know what you're
talking about is really scary the idea
of asking for feedback from your boss or
asking for a raise really scary the idea
of going in and talking your professor
about adjusting your grade really scary
the idea of raising your hand i get it i
read your emails i see the comments but
you've got to understand that this is
the number one skill that you need
in order to increase your visibility
wherever it is that you need to increase
your visibility
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video i've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the lessons learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there rule number five cut yourself a
break the world doesn't need another
perfect person
the world needs you
and you're trying your best
you're doing what you can
and you know i think it's really
important that you cut yourself a break
and that you stop thinking that you have
to be perfect there are going to be days
where you're an hour late to pick up
your kid and that's okay
there are going to be days when you
can't get to every email and that's okay
there are going to be days where you
feel so underwater and that's okay
you'll get through it you'll figure it
out and you've got to understand that
it's not about being perfect
it's about just being you
and that means that you got to be
willing to start before you're ready you
got to be willing to
do what i do every damn day which is
show up in my rollers or start a live
stream and disconnect myself or start it
and be talking and not even know that
i'm broadcasting
you've got to do that version in your
life or you're not going to get ahead
period rule number six don't judge
yourself instead of doing what so many
of us do when we're broken up with and
we go i'm a loser i'm unlovable i'm not
good enough
what i want you to do instead is i want
you to put that opinion and judgment on
the relationship itself
that relationship that's over wasn't
good enough
wasn't worthy and wasn't the right fit
for love for you
do not take that on as an internal
judgment of yourself
make sure that when you're judging it
you're judging the relationship and how
it wasn't a good fit for you
you my friend are whole you my friend
are perfect how you are and yeah you may
have to change yeah yeah there's things
that you can do better now that you know
better yes there's baggage you got to
deal with but there's nothing wrong with
you there's just patterns that you need
to deal with rule number seven love the
process of pursuing goals you'll get the
day
where you celebrate and that was
yesterday
and
you'll have that moment where you cannot
believe that you actually got into the
school that you wanted or you got the
job that you wanted or you found the
person that that really complements you
finally or that you got the raise that
you wanted or you built the house that
you've always dreamt of and then a funny
thing happens after you actually achieve
the dream
after you celebrate
life goes right back to the way that it
was
and for me what i'm present to is not
the fact that this talk show's actually
happening it's i'm focused on all the
work that i now need to do
in order to do the talk show as
powerfully as i can
and i think
that
the point that i'm trying to make about
the fact that yeah you can achieve all
the things that you're going for but
i've even noticed already in just 24
hours like that the crazy rise in
emotion and excitement has already been
replaced with things are back to normal
that is exactly what psychologists talk
about when it comes to happiness because
happiness is not about achieving things
it's not about getting the result it's
about
how you
pursue the things
that you enjoy and why you're pursuing
them and so
the key to life and i'm seeing it happen
in my own life is not actually checking
the boxes and getting all those things
that you dream about it's
how you go about living your life as
you're pursuing them because if i were
just gonna like check the box and now
i'm done biggest goal of my life to have
a daytime talk show just achieve that
what do i have to look forward to
nothing if you've already achieved it
which is why it's so important for you
to
understand that the real meaning of
happiness is about how you show up every
day yes you should have big goals yes
you should have big dreams yes yes yes
and yes you should pursue them
but don't ever think that quote making
your dreams come true is what actually
makes you happy because what actually
makes you happy is having those big
dreams and waking up every morning and
doing a little something to push
yourself to make them happen it's about
the pursuit rule number eight have
empathy it's really important for your
personal boundaries to use what i always
talk about which is empathy understand
that anybody that's acting out it
doesn't excuse the behavior it explains
it and it also allows you to separate
yourself emotionally that person is
likely miserable that person has a bad
life which is why they treat people
badly and so if you can start to really
use empathy to put it on them versus
making it that they are doing something
to you that can help you from getting
hooked emotionally rule number nine be a
fan if you start shifting the dynamic
and here's how you do it you do it by
being a fan what do i mean i talk about
this all the time if you google mel
robbins being a fan you'll probably come
up with like 10 different videos on
youtube about this philosophy it's a
philosophy about leading with
appreciation it's a philosophy about
cheering for other people publicly
because what happens when you cheer for
other people
is you naturally trigger the law of
reciprocity and even the biggest jerk
face even the biggest curmudgeon even
the biggest most competitive person on
the planet who might be competitive by
the way because she's paying for her
parents
nursing home bill
and she's feeling stressed out and she's
also divorced i mean who knows what's
driving this competitive nature maybe
it's a sense of scarcity and fear and
insecurity
and so the opposite of competition isn't
more competition it's connection
and you create connection
by cheering for people and rule number
10 the last one before a very special
bonus clip is have the courage to speak
up the majority of people lack
self-awareness at work
you get that
the person who's disrespecting you
likely doesn't even know what they're
doing
the person who's taking his or her anger
out on you
likely doesn't know how it's impacting
you you see when people do this when
they have these kind of toxic patterns
they've been getting away with them for
so long because nobody has had the
courage to cross-check them verbally on
it and that's where you come in lucky
you
you're in their life because your
purpose in their life is to be the one
person that has the courage to actually
sit down and have a candid conversation
about it so what are you going to do how
do you have that candid conversation
first of all try not to make them wrong
try not to come in and shame them and
tell them all the horrible things
they're doing because you'll immediately
create a situation where they're
defensive and if the research bears out
from harvard business school and they
actually had no idea that they were
doing it they might get defensive
the better way to do it the more
effective way to do it is to explain
how their behavior impacts you
and when you do that
most people are mortified
because most people
are venting or are disrespectful and
they're not even thinking about the
impact it has because nobody's ever told
them
understand
that
you can find people to support you
you will always find people to criticize
you
watch though how when somebody outside
of you criticizes you
how that triggers the internal pattern
so what is the pattern that you have of
thinking
that gets triggered that disempowers you
that i won't have any words you won't
have any words let's go deeper than that
is it something about being loved or
being unworthy or not being good enough
what is underneath i won't have the
words
yeah they won't be the right words and i
it won't be good enough yeah okay and so
do you have an opinion that you're not
good enough or not deserving of success
or that you're not
smart enough to make a difference
yeah what is the one what is what is the
thing that hooks you
that you say to yourself
that i'm stupid that they're okay there
we go that's a good one not a good one
but you know what i mean that's a good
one because that's my baby okay i'm a
piece of
now we're talking yeah that's the big
one who told you that
i don't i don't know who told me that
when did you start believing that
it's a little girl yeah
god i've just been saying it for so long
i i don't know
that's okay she said i've been saying it
for so long i don't know
as you now know what you're looking for
you're gonna start to connect the dots
okay and so here's the thing
at some point
you started telling yourself whatever
i'm a piece
as a strategy
you did it on purpose as a youngster
as a way to survive things that were
happening because maybe when you said
well i'm a piece of you actually got
really quiet and you didn't get hit
or maybe when you said that you uh
removed yourself from situations
when you would have been abused or
something it worked because it protected
you as weird as it sounds yeah
is that are you seeing something what
are you saying
well yeah my dad didn't want he wanted
me to be quiet in the corner being quiet
yeah he couldn't
make noise and okay
and if you got if you raised your voice
you got in trouble
so do you guys see the link now between
why she has a concern about finding her
words
oh yeah i didn't get that one you see
that now yeah so
every time that you
are in a situation where you need to
speak up how many of you relating to
this by the way
i have a theory about all of us
that we have
patterns and strategies that we we
created when we were little
in order to survive situations
and what she
internalized was don't speak up
and you're a piece of [ __ ] you do
and
believe me that protected your ass it
worked because you didn't speak up and
you didn't get in trouble with your dad
right and i still got the love so if i
speak up now i'm going to lose my dad's
love do you see this
so this is a pattern that got
written when she was little
and it was written by someone else and
it worked it worked
the problem is now that you're working
now it's not working now
it's not working now not working now and
see
exactly and so this is what's
fascinating about all this there are
places in your life where you have
patterns that you don't even recognize
that were strategies that you developed
when you were a kid and so in the areas
where you're really frustrated that
pattern is probably
not
present or conscious
something that you're aware of
and so every single time because you've
been repeating this and repeating it and
repeating it every single time you're
about to hit play every single time
you're going to stand on stage what's
going to be right there is don't speak
up
you're
yes freeze and you're gonna go five four
three two one the only thing to
that actually overrides this pattern is
to speak
and through speaking
you will see
that you're not a piece of [ __ ]
you actually have something to say
or you could make fun of it and say well
i guess i'm just a piece of something to
say
that's right and i also like the
strategy of kind of making the fun of
the stuff
even the heavy stuff
because it loses its grip on me it works
for me it may not work for you
but it's something to try give yourself
permission
to dream with the lid off
this is really important and the reason
why this is important is because i
guarantee you
that right now you are not even allowing
yourself
to fully
dream or
think about or set goals that are truly
aligned with what you deeply want in
your heart
that you aren't even able to manifest
properly because you're not even honest
with yourself about what you actually
want this is a really common thing
because you're allowing your self-doubt
you are allowing your fears your anxiety
your insecurity you're allowing where
you are to dictate and limit where you
want to go and so step one super
important you must allow yourself
give yourself permission to start
dreaming with the lid off now the
scientific reason why this is so
important is because you have a filter
in your brain called the reticular
activity system
i write about the ras for short the
reticular activity system extensively in
the high five habit
the ras is a filter in your mind and you
can
do simple things that change the
structure of that filter in fact the
filter in your mind the res is always
changing so one thing that you can do
in order to teach yourself how to
dream with the lid off is to
adopt a simple habit every single
morning i do a very simple thing i write
down five things that i want
that's it
when i start my day after i get up on
the alarm rings i make my bed i pull on
my exercise clothes i set an intention i
high-five myself in the mirror i then go
out into the kitchen i crack open my
high five journal and then inside the
journal there are prompts that walk me
through the steps of visualizing and the
first prompt is dream with the lid off
set your spirit free write down five
things every morning that you want and
this is important because when you get
what you want out of your head
and you physically put them on a piece
of paper research shows that you're 42
percent more likely to achieve those
goals simply by writing them down that's
pretty cool
secondly your mind is paying attention
and when you take deliberate action and
you write down what you want you are
signaling to your brain
that you
deserve to have these things you are
signaling to your brain that you do want
those things you're not just going to
think about them these are things that
matter to you and that helps train your
mind to allow you to let the desires
flow through you because right now
you're not manifesting properly because
you're not even allowing yourself to
dream with the lid off so that's step
number one you're gonna start writing
down five things that you want every
single morning as a way to train your
mind to let you dream freely you need to
do the work okay
you gotta do the work
because it's only through your actions
that you will accomplish what you want
let's say uh that you've always wanted
to climb a particular mountain okay
there's a mountain called haystack it's
not even that tall so i should probably
pick a bigger one but let's just call it
haystack mountain you've always wanted
to climb haystack mountain you pull up
to haystack mountain
and you get out of the car you park at
the you know national forest parking lot
and you make the mistake of looking up
at the mountain which is the end goal
right
and you notice it's up in the clouds
and then you start to think oh my god
that's a really far way away
you know i don't really know how i feel
about doing this anymore because that
looks like it's going to take a really
long time and then all of a sudden it
starts to rain and you go i don't think
i want to do this because i don't think
i feel like doing this and next thing
you know you are back in the car driving
back down the road to that little diner
that you saw and instead of climbing the
mountain that you've always dreamt of
climbing you've now
come up with an excuse
and you have abandoned ship you now have
literally become your own obstacle you
talked yourself out of it you started to
doubt yourself you told yourself you
weren't ready and that you didn't feel
like it
you pull the rip cord you're out of
there in order to have what you want in
life
you must stop staring at the top of that
mountain
you must stop creating excuses for why
you can't or don't feel like it and you
must put your head down
and look at the first step in front of
you
and then you must take the action and
start walking toward what you want and
it'll be a hell of a lot easier for you
to do that if you have also been putting
in the time every day consistently to
not only see yourself
walking up that trail step by step but
that you have felt yourself pushing
through the resistance the fear the
obstacles the the excuses that are
stopping you now and feel proud in every
fiber of your being as you push through
those obstacles and see yourself and
feel yourself doing the work
that's how you manifest properly
and if you do that before you pull into
the
national park parking lot
if you look up at that mountain and you
see clouds and it starts raining it
won't matter
because you've already rehearsed this
moment in your mind body and spirit
and you my friend will start walking up
that trail
and you're going to be proud if you
struggle with boundaries i want you to
know you're not alone and this is super
common
and um one of the reasons why i'm
excited to share everything that i've
learned about boundaries with you is
because i used to be the kind of person
that had zero boundaries i mean nada
nothing zilch nothing in fact there were
periods of my life where it was worse
than zero because i was so attached in
romantic relationships that i literally
would become like a human amoeba
in my romantic relationships i mean i
was like literally if it's possible to
have negative boundaries
meaning you like somehow go in a totally
different direction
that was me and so if somebody as
insecure
and as uh emotionally attached in
relationships and as people pleasing as
me can figure out how to
identify
communicate
and uphold boundaries in my life
you can learn how to do this too okay
and so that's what we're gonna unpack
in this video
so i think a big question because a lot
of people talk about boundaries they
know they need boundaries but
they don't
have good boundaries why is that
well the reason why
we don't have good boundaries is because
none of us were trained how to set them
i mean i want you to think about your
childhood for a minute
your childhood with your caregivers your
parents or grandparents whoever it is
naturally an imbalance right like when
you come into this world you are born
into a particular family you're born
into a particular culture religion
economic situation a place in the world
a race like a religion and
based on where you were born and to whom
you were born into in terms of the
family structure
there were all kinds of rules that you
had to follow and if you did not follow
those rules
there were consequences and so can you
imagine
if you as like an eight-year-old started
to try to express boundaries literally
like mom cooks a uh you know a pot pot
roast dinner and you cross your arms
you're like you know mom
uh this is a boundary cross for me i
have decided that i am no longer eating
meat
uh your mom would probably go guess what
youngster you not eating dinner is a
boundary crossing for me you're not
getting up from this table until you
finish what's on your plate and so
saying boundaries when you're little
doesn't really work for the adults in
your life and that's why you never
learned how to do it and by the way your
parents were probably never taught how
to have boundaries either and so
i want to start at the very beginning
okay
where do you even begin
where do you even begin when it comes to
learning how to set healthy boundaries
okay
so
first things first where you're going to
begin is you're going to start to think
about boundaries in a completely new way
okay
the number one mistake that we all make
i made it you're making it right now is
when you think about boundaries you are
thinking about other people first okay
you're thinking about boundaries uh and
believing that your boundaries are rules
in a relationship that define respect
and that somehow your boundaries are
going to control or change someone
else's behavior
that is the exact opposite of how you
should be thinking about boundaries okay
and i'm going to give you a bunch of
examples don't worry i didn't realize
this this is why i was lousy at setting
boundaries because i thought that my
boundaries control what other people do
no no no no no so how do i want you to
think about boundaries okay
boundaries
are rules
that you create
about your own behavior
yep i'm going to say that again
boundaries are rules that you create
about your own behavior
so many of us have this perfectionism
gene and the reason why we're
perfectionists is we're trying to
insulate ourselves from criticism that
if you get it perfect no one will give
you feedback if you get it right
nobody's going to criticize you if you
do it perfect then no one will be able
to attack you and the problem with that
and that's just another side of the same
coin which is the fear of disappointing
people you're managing not disappointing
people not by lying and not by being
codependent but by actually trying to be
a perfectionist so that nobody
criticizes you so let me tell you a
story about the fear of disappointing
people in my own life because this is
the biggest trigger in my life i mean it
goes back to being in fourth grade right
it's there and this is another thing i i
literally have to remind myself of this
everybody every single day you cannot
remove the things that trigger you you
can't if you've been doing a pattern
since fourth grade there will be things
for the rest of your life that will
trigger that pattern to come up but you
can always choose not to repeat the
pattern so you'll be triggered and be
afraid that you're going to disappoint
somebody that's real that's normal it's
natural it's part of being a human being
i think it's interwoven into every
relationship where you love somebody but
you don't have to behave the way that
you always behaved when you're nervous
about disappointing somebody so let me
give you a dumb story you ready when my
husband and i got married my father gave
us this really incredible gift he gave
us an antique pool table i grew up in
muskegon michigan where brunswick was
founded and my dad has a hobby of going
to garage sales and estate sales and
buying old dilapidated pool tables and
then he restores them so when chris and
i got married he bought us an old
dilapidated pool table from the same era
as our house which is the 1870s he
restored the whole thing and then
recently he and i rented a u-haul and we
drove this sucker from muskegon michigan
to boston massachusetts my dad and i
took a road trip get there and we
assemble the pool table in what used to
be our playroom fast forward three or
four years the speaking business takes
off my business starts to grow we have
people that work for us and my kids are
older we don't need a playroom we need
an office the pool table is in the
middle of this thing for the first two
years of having the office we kept the
pool table there why because i didn't
want my dad to be disappointed because i
love him now he visits our house twice a
year for two or three days with my mom
and i kept this thing occupying a third
of our office for two years and then i
realized i'm being ridiculous i'm being
absolutely ridiculous now here's the
thing will he be disappointed if i take
the pool table down absolutely
definitely there are always going to be
things that you do decisions that you
have to make in your life in your
business for your family that will
disappoint other people it's unavoidable
but the fact that he's going to be
disappointed should never be the reason
that i don't do something that is
aligned with my values
now let's take it a step further when
you make a decision that is likely going
to disappoint people or that does still
make the decision because it's your life
there's nothing worse than when you
start to rob your future and your life
and your happiness because you're so
focused on other people however if you
love people you can still take care of
them when you make that decision so let
me go back to the example of the pool
table so i knew i was going to take it
down i knew my father was going to be
disappointed i was disappointed i don't
have a big house so i don't you know i
don't have the room for a huge pool
table i don't have a finished basement
like a lot of people i don't have like a
cool garage game room thing like i just
don't have it i called him first and
said i need to talk to you about
something you know the pool table i love
the pool table dad my business is
growing so much i actually need an
office and oh great it'll be great in
the office and i'm like well
yeah it would except i have you know
three or four people showing up we gotta
put some desks in there for now even
went down well you could put a piece of
plywood they could work on the pool
table and then they could do the thing
and then the thing and now my heart is
racing because i don't want to
disappoint my dad and now he's fighting
for the and i had to just say for me dad
here's what's going to happen i'm going
to hire professional movers in the pool
table business to disassemble this with
love and care we're going to store it
beautifully when
i either get a full-time office off-site
or i build a barn or i build a different
house this will have its own beautiful
room dedicated to you so we had this
beautiful conversation now was he
disappointed absolutely when they come
to the house and visit which they just
did and they walk into the office do i
feel a pang you better believe i do it
doesn't matter that's all normal i still
need to make the decisions that i need
to make and the difference what's
changed is how i relate to that fear so
instead of what i would do in the past
is i would make a decision that doesn't
serve me i'd leave the pool table and
then i'd be all about it i'd leave the
pool table as a way to make my dad happy
but it makes me miserable to leave it
there because i need the space right and
then i'd be kind of annoyed and then
he'd come and i'd fake play pool because
i kind of want to write you know you
know what i'm saying like we do all this
that's not real and what i've been able
to do for myself in some instances when
i catch it is to hit it head-on and to
be authentic and to still take care of
people and what i've also come to learn
is that people can be disappointed in
you and they still love you you know
you're never going to get around this
everybody in your family is going to be
disappointed with you probably once a
day probably and you have the ability to
retrain how you respond to that trigger
that rises up in you where you start to
fear that you're disappointing somebody
and the answer really is make the
decision that's aligned with your values
and the thing that supports you and then
take care of the person by being honest
and straightforward about it dealing
with their disappointment head on
because that's really the adult thing to
do and that's what you do when you love
somebody the way we've all been handling
it myself included is manipulation lying
resentment withholding and that doesn't
serve anybody the reason why
visualization and picturing yourself
succeeding and allowing yourself to feel
the happiness and the pride that comes
with picturing a positive future the
reason why that's as important is let's
say shelley does that every single day
this week
every day she wakes up she walks for
five minutes and as she's walking on
that treadmill she's visualizing herself
finishing a 10k in six months and how
proud she is
every time she does that she is changing
what's going on up here
this isn't something i made up this is
true
and it's not only true based on science
but let's think about this from a common
sense perspective
if shelley wakes up or if you wake up
every single morning
and instead of thinking about the worst
case instead of looking at your body in
the mirror and going i'm so fat i'm so
out of shape i'll never run a 10k this
is never going to happen why didn't i
exercise last year i hate my flabby
stomach i hate my my big thighs i hate
how out of shape i'm embarrassed to go
like if that's what you're thinking
then that is what
you're allowing your brain
to continue to filter the world through
if you start
teaching yourself the skill of
visualizing a positive outcome and
feeling the pride that comes with
achieving that positive goal what
happens for you right now
is you start to think like the kind of
person that does a 10k
if after an entire week what shelly does
is she get looks in the mirror and she
goes i'm getting stronger every day i'm
really proud of myself even though i'm
i'm feeling flabby i'm not saying you're
flabby shelly but even though i'm
feeling flabby i'm doing the work i can
do this what happens a week from now is
when she sees a registration for a 10k
the old mind that wasn't programmed
correctly would go oh you're fat you're
out of shape you're not prepared for
that don't sign up
but the new mind
because she's been visualizing every
single day
the new mind just seven to ten days
later is going to go oh wait a minute
i'm in shape i'm proud i'm doing this
why do you sign up
it's going to filter the world in a very
different way because you're training it
to
this is the heart of doing a mindset
reset and this is why visualization
works and why it's an important step and
why i'm so glad you're doing it part of
the reason why you don't feel productive
is because you're trying to complete
everything and so let's take one of the
things that i saw somebody write that
you want to
clean up one of the spare rooms in your
apartment or in your house that maybe
there's a spare bedroom and you have
been wanting to turn it into a home
office or maybe one of the kids has
moved out of the house and you want to
de-clutter that room like a project
around organizing maybe it's something
in your garage or your basement or hey
here's one for me
our daughter moved out and started her
life uh you know post college and our
other daughter is out in los angeles
going to college and we no joke
have
three garbage bags full of clothes
that somebody needs to go through to
figure out what needs to be donated what
could you actually sell because it still
has tags on it and it has been sitting
there for two months so maybe you have a
pile of that kind of stuff in your house
this is not a priority for me
i'm perfectly fine with it sitting in
the room where our laundry is the
priority for me this week is to carve
out dedicated time to hang out with our
16 year old son and do something fun
together because we spend a lot of time
together but we don't get intentional
about doing something specific but if
you want to declutter for example here's
where we all go wrong you identify what
you want to do and then you think you
got to get it done
in order for me to go through two bags
of clothing for example in order for you
to clear out your garage
that could take you two days to do it
the right way right
because
you know if you don't give yourself
enough time then you're going to piles
and so then you think i can't get it
done and so then you never schedule it
right okay
we're not going to worry about
completion everybody
we're going to worry about progress
so when you think about things in terms
of progress it can shrink the amount of
time that you need maybe all that you're
going to do is you're going to work on
one dresser in the room
or you're going to work on one shelving
unit in the garage
and by simply making the time to number
one identify what matters to you and
number two identify what meaningful
progress could look like
you will now shrink the amount of time
you will define the project and you can
make the time for it and simply just
doing that is going to make you feel
more productive based on the research
all right now let me talk about um
what you need to do okay i literally
have notes for this oh there we go and i
just lost it because i really want to
make sure that i teach you all this
stuff
so um here becca can you help me because
this is not oh because my thing is not
never mind guys i am tr i am trying
multitasking is not how you be
productive and you are watching me
multitask right now
we're going to get into some of the
science now
so now that is how you leverage
something called the progress principle
okay the progress principle is really
important when it comes to productivity
this is a concept that i first learned
about in the harvard business review so
if it's in the harvard business review
everybody very fancy must be accurate
right if it's coming from harvard well
the progress principle is a study that
uh comes from a study where researchers
looked at i believe it was 14 000 work
journals and what they found after
looking at the work journals of how
people spent their time 14 000 people is
that at the end of the week the people
that felt like they had been the most
productive and the people who felt the
most fulfilled by their work week were
the people who simply made progress
on something that mattered and so by you
identifying what matters to you this
week and by you identifying a way that
you can make a small amount of progress
on it you are leveraging this research
research from harvard business review
about what creates productivity and
meaning and fulfillment in your life and
that's making progress on something that
matters when you wake up generally what
the research shows is that your brain is
primed to be able to focus for the first
four hours of the day the first four
hours of the day tend to be for most of
us the time of day when your brain has
the most fuel and when your speed of
processing is awesome and when you are
able to direct your attention at what
you need to be focused on there's a
caveat to this you can manufacture
boosts of productivity and boosts of
feeling like you've got a little bit
more brain power number one immediately
after you exercise if you have a burst
of cardio 30 minutes is what a lot of
the research says but if you have a
burst of cardio you will get a little
bit of increase in fuel another thing
that helps is getting outside when you
start to feel your energy and your focus
start to go to empty getting outside is
another way to give yourself a boost of
brain power but generally speaking
everybody you need to start to
marry mornings with peak productivity if
you can own your mornings if you can put
that thing that matters to you first
thing in the morning and make a little
bit of progress on it you are going to
start to feel like you are more in
control you're going to start to see
yourself using your best brain power and
your highest level of fuel at the thing
that matters most to you first of all
you got to give yourself permission to
really
have what you want okay because you've
got to have the thing that you're
visualizing be something that is
authentically something that you want
number two you must see yourself taking
the steps the tiny actions and doing the
work that will lead you to creating or
having what you want
third you got to feel in your body what
it feels like to do the work and you
also have to feel pride as you see
yourself doing the work because that
amplifies your mind body and spirit
really
imprinting and training and preparing
for it and fourth
obviously you got to take the actions
and all of that manifesting and
preparing inspires you to take the
actions
but one place where so many folks get
stuck when they start trying to make
manifesting a daily habit
is you go and you know what you want
but then you sit down and you try to
imagine
what the steps are that you need to take
to get there
and you don't have a clue
your mind goes blank if this is you i'm
so excited that you're watching this
because the simple trick based in
science is called the power of
objectivity all you got to do is stop
visualizing yourself and insert your
friend mel robbins or insert somebody
else that you love and admire
and the power of objectivity is going to
immediately switch you from a blocked
mind to one that is bolder and more
creative and able to visualize the steps
now i'm not just making this up there's
extraordinary research that was just
written about in the harvard business
school review they did eight different
studies at the university of wisconsin
where they were studying the power of
objectivity and with thousands of
participants here's what they found when
participants tried to visualize
themselves
doing hard things
immediately the participants when they
thought about themselves doing something
hard like let's just say asking for a
raise okay i want you to imagine
yourself asking for a raise or applying
for that dream job when you visualize
yourself doing it you immediately focus
in on minutia you start imagining all
kinds of things that could go wrong you
start arguing against yourself and doubt
comes flooding in you have a very
cautious mindset when you place yourself
in those scenarios
however
if you were to visualize me mel robbins
asking for that raise
immediately your mindset switches to
being very bold being creative seeing
all kinds of opportunities and in fact
when you not only visualize me your
friend mel robbins asking for that raise
that you want when you give me advice
you're super enthusiastic you're like
mel you should go for it and i bet in
your life
you have probably
told friends or loved ones you should
ask for more money and you mean it
because you're visualizing them but you
yourself
won't visualize yourself doing that you
talk yourself out of it we've all had
this experience you yourself are
probably sitting there going you're
right mel i constantly tell my friends
you deserve more you should break up
with that jerk
you should go for it
but when it comes to yourself
you see the excuses of death so i want
you to leverage not only this common
sense but this research to your
advantage when it comes to manifesting
pick what you want and then if your mind
goes blank when it comes to seeing
yourself do the work literally just
insert your friend mel robbins or insert
anybody that you love when i hear the
word productivity
i don't want you to think about plowing
through a to-do list because part of the
reason why you don't feel productive
is because you're busy doing the things
that aren't important to you
yeah do you need to make sure you have
milk or you got almond milk or oat milk
in the fridge of course you do but have
you ever noticed that all the busy crap
in life
uh tends to take care of itself
that you don't really need to focus your
time and energy on the minutia that's on
your to-do list because that stuff tends
to grab your attention
what you really need to do is figure out
how to create time and how to create the
focus that you need
in order to feel like you are making
progress
on the important things
and that's really
what productivity means to me
you get all kinds of stuff done you're
really busy in your life aren't you
but are you getting
progress made
on the important things
probably not because that's the
challenge for most of us and so first
things first when it comes to trying to
have a breakthrough in productivity you
need a game plan
you need to have a very short list every
week of what actually matters to you
okay
because i guarantee you if you were to
do an audit of the way that you spend
your time this week you would probably
see
that 95 of your time
is spent on things that you really don't
care about
and even more scary i bet you don't even
realize how much time you are wasting
just mindlessly scrolling through social
media or sitting on the couch with the
tv on also answering emails that is the
least productive way to spend your time
multitasking spending your time just
sort of zoning out on things that don't
matter
what i want you to do is i want you
right now to think about
what is it between now and the end of
this week for example what is it
that matters to you what's the most
important thing
that you would love to make progress on
that you never seem to find the time
okay
it's a whole nother conversation for us
to talk about whether or not you
actually have time because the fact is
you do have time you have plenty of time
to make small amount of progress every
single day on what matters to you
what you do not have right now is you do
not have a plan
for
prioritizing
the important stuff in your life
[Music]
because you made it this far in a video
i want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but you
are different you are special believe
nation you made it here all the way to
the end and i love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments below on this video
i will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because
you are awesome to see my recent
interview with mel robbins one on one
check the video right there next to me i
think you'll love it continue to believe
and i'll see you there i hope your
business goes bankrupt evan evan you're
a terrible person i spent the first
40 some years of my life trying to be
somebody else i'll give you guys a
secret way